one hello hello sorry i had i um i used the bathroom i was
like i was like i'm ready and then i was like wait i got it
i got used to bathroom brb also so you know like those
moments when um um when you're eating some i i had lunch
earlier and then i had something stuck on my in my in my 10
minutes trying to get it out.
Oh, I hate that feeling so much.
And I got so paranoid because I was trying to use my tongue
to, um, get whatever the fuck that was, like the, the,
whatever food was in my tooth or like my gums.
And then, um, and then like I got so paranoid because I was
like, oh, wait, my tongue keeps like rubbing that tooth.
Will it make my tooth worse?
And then I yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I got really paranoid.
So I was in like this Google rep.
It was like five And it's like five minutes till the stream.
Let me look this up to make sure I'm not fucking mickey.
And I found out apparently if you use your tongue to like
rub against your tooth too much, you can cause teeth
erosion.
And I was like, oh no.
And then it caused me to keep rubbing my tongue against the
tooth because that's all I could think about.
I was just like, oh my God, I need to stop doing it.
And I'm still like rubbing my tongue against it.
I was like, wait, no.
I did it's like no stop and then yeah yeah apparently it's
real like you can cause erosion on your tooth um if you keep
rubbing your tongue against it and I was just like oh no
it's like don't think about breathing and then you're like
now now I'm like periodically rubbing against it I'm like no
it's eroding my teeth I'm like freaking out anyway that's
basically what's been going on um The last 20 minutes I've
been like freaking out He's being casted manual breathing
Now I may Now you guys will have to suffer too No it's not I
googled it in everything Google is the best doctor You know
instead of going to an actual doctor or dentist I just
googled my problems away Also Derek and Ash Welcome to
tomato farm Welcome, welcome Satan, thank you for the super
chat Thank you, thank you let me uh let me pin the tweet pin
sign up tweet pin the comment real quick about the uh
membership stuff so people will know uh where to go all
right um if you are a member if you are a member you can you
too can join the doki smp read the post here to find out how
to link your count all right here you go i i cannot be
bothered to uh spell check that um anyway uh like i said
this week is more uh more chill week so i am less i guess
i'm just all over the place i'm just saying whatever the
fuck's on my mind right now my brain is like super frazzled
this week so um next way i am taking a couple more days off
um like i think i'll take like sunday monday and tuesday off
just to reset myself because I do I definitely feel the
fatigue hitting me this week but I still wanted to stream
because I just wanted to hang out with my dragons this week
but definitely Monday Tuesday like Sunday Monday and Tuesday
I'll be taking uh three days off in a row just to reset
myself a little because my brain is very frazzled at the
moment um what else do I want to tell you guys about before
oh you know let's let's get in uh there's gonna be no war
crimes committed as
um and also uh for oh yeah i forgot to set up my music see i
told you guys i'm all over the place i don't even have music
playing uh yeah you know let's just have minecraft music
playing but so that couldn't hurt like for once let's just
play minecraft music for once all right uh where is mine i
haven't had minecraft all right there you go let's do some
classic okay let's just have minecraft music we haven't
heard minecraft music in so long what is that guy still in
purgatory the server is shut down at the moment uh so except
for me i have a privilege to be in there um but don't worry
we might we might uh let let the gates open later on i mean
we could see all right let's see oh still have god mode whoa
uh enjoy your well-deserved us next week dokey we dragons
are glad you're taking your time for yourself thank you and
something thank you Alette, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki and Dragoons.
I got a question for y'all.
How does your tongue lay in your mouth?
Thank you for the super chat, Alette.
Thank you.
It's at the bottom.
I know some people have it on the roof of their mouths, but
mine's at the bottom.
And then now everybody's going to be thinking about it.
Where is... Okay.
I forgot the commands.
TP home.
T-P-Doki-Lon?
Teleport Doki-Berdo to Doki-Lon.
There we go.
Oh, there's my house.
Wait, wait.
Is it my house?
Where am I?
This is not...
Where's my house?
I want the Doki-Lon.
Where's my prison?
Oh, there you go.
Nice.
Wait, where is this?
Captured ghosts from...
Oh, there it is!
Oh, yay!
Oh, mods, do I have any...
Are any of my Minecraft?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, there you go.
Minecraft mod!
White list el mexicant.
So only he can be allowed in the server.
Just only let him...
him in the server.
No one else.
Just let him log in.
Why list that man right now?
That dear.
Is he even online?
I don't know.
I don't working on as evil.
I'm gonna explore the server but make sure he's in that
prison cell.
Oh yeah, for those who don't know, this is my prison cell.
So anyone that...
I would kidnap one tribute.
I'll hold one hostage from each land.
It's like the Hunger Games, where each land sends me their
tribute.
But instead of sending it to me, I kidnap one.
So to make sure they don't piss me off, I kidnap all their
most prized possessions or pets.
And make sure that they don't fuck with anyone.
No one can fuck with me.
uh yeah it's that's that yeah it's a sacrifice to make sure
nobody does anything bad in my server uh yeah it's like
they're technically volunteers volunteers from each area so
um i know it says captured but that's like a typo it should
be like volunteered cat from shopping district uh
volunteered horse from shopping district volunteer ghost
from mexico and jerk gas from Mexico and Germany.
Volunteered player from the void.
An order from our president and queen and king and emperor.
Volunteered horse from the volunteer player.
You consider freeing the animals at you.
They volunteered themselves to be here, Lafayette.
They give the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
GG's, thank you for the super yes, thank you for the super
chat, thank you thank you oh my god, he's like freaking out
so if you're in this chat for the love of Dragoon, don't log
in, is he not here?
Okay, Dragoon um admin, admin, let one person in to the
server who would be a substitute for our humble volunteer
because he's not here to check he's not here to clock in for
their 9 to 5 He didn't show up for his shift.
So let in one intern into the server.
Just one.
Open the floodgates.
But not the flood, like a raindrop.
Open the raindrop gates.
All right.
Added.
There you go.
One E-E-U-Lax.
You're allowed into the...
We have a special E-E-U-Lax.
Congratulations.
We have a special prize for you.
We have a very special prize for you.
That you won the lottery.
You were the 500th customer in the server.
Would you like to claim your prize?
You know, like those pop-up ads.
You were the 500 person to visit this site.
Click here to claim your prize.
TP him into that gate.
Admin.
TP that man into this gate.
And kick everyone else.
Alright, remember to claim your prize.
Lucky dragon.
Oh, so much luck.
There we go.
Congratulations.
you lax you won an amazing prize you get a one month
vacation in this amazing hotel room
congratulations it's a free one month staycation in this
hotel room all right let's go
all expenses not paid for remember by the end of the month
you gotta make sure you pay me uh 500 uh because that this
sorry this hotel room is not cheap i'm beginning to believe
um it is not a scam this is a wonderful opportunity look at
the view Look at the amazing view you can see here.
All right, let's let's explore.
Oh my gosh.
I hope also the toilet is in that corner, by the way.
That corner over there, that's the toilet.
So don't worry, it will be emptied once every month.
So we'll be back.
All right, let's explore.
All right, admin, TP to a place for me to explore to happen
what the wait okay wait actually admin get over here get
over here get over here get over here get over here admin
get over here chop that finger off remove remove that finger
to make it a fist remove the finger right now i demand this
finger to be removed chop it off What does it say at the top
here?
Well, we'll never know.
Chop the finger off!
That's wrong!
Oh my god!
That's right!
Don't fuck with me, I'll chop, I can chop fingers.
Alright.
Eviction notice.
Move out, or I will take more fingers.
There we go.
It's not a war crime.
It's just a regular crime.
There we go.
All right.
Do they still...
Okay, what's this?
Chapel.
Do they still have their stupid fucking...
Oh, it's this.
This is the honor, so please don't delete things.
Only winners write history.
Only winners write the history.
Nice.
Alright.
TP me to a place to explore.
Edmund.
TP me to somewhere.
We haven't gone to before.
Is he still there?
Are you in...
Oh, shit.
Where am I?
Have you played Goo Goo Baby?
with your life on the what the fuck is this what damn that
what where did where is this place what is the fuck is this
let me know the sound is okay is this like the villager dead
welcome to D What the fuck is this place?
It's super creepy.
Dude.
Fucked up amusement park ride 500.
This is an amusement park?
What is this?
Ball Fondler 5000.
Ball destroyer.
I don't even know where to start in this hell.
they worked really hard yeah I am so confused what's this oh
what oh there's like uh what are they called wait he's not
destroying anything wait that's crazy this feels like
creative AI oh yeah like Minecraft AI.
They kind of generated this.
We took...
We took bed.
Is there anything we could kidnap?
We could take as tribute?
Who is very important here?
Alright.
I know like...
Okay, why do you have so many librarians?
You don't take this man.
We kidnap him.
I mean we we take him as a tribute to our prison cell Take
this man.
I demand this this guy.
No, we are not taking the wither.
I think the wither will destroy
Take him I Demand this guy as our tribute
No, Doki he had a family exactly Yes, and yeah, all right
there he goes.
Whoa, what?
What?
Alright, why did you take him down here?
I need to make sure every lad has a- it's like we're making
our very own hunger games.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I got- I- don't worry, let me get out.
How the fuck do you get out of here?
I don't know how to get out.
Like where's the exit?
Oh my god, I swear I'm going fucking crazy with that.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Where's the exit?
Oh my god, I don't think there is an exit.
They ran on a budget for the fucking exit.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
There has to be a way out.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, I think I found the exit.
What the fuck?
Oh, the guys literally built in a fucking dungeon?
Oh, my God.
You guys built it in the dungeon.
Okay, wait.
I'm getting out.
I'm TPing out of here myself.
L spawn Doki Lan.
There you go.
Oh, where am I?
Oh, back to my lovely home.
Okay.
Where is he?
Where's my new tribute?
You know what?
Give it to this guy.
Put him in it.
Put the guy in there.
New roommate.
No, no, no.
Hang him.
But like in game.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no.
Hang him, in game.
That's like a little ride.
Oh, wait.
Add.
There you go.
Is it not?
Oh.
Time.
Add.
Seconds.
Where's my morning?
Time.
Oh, there he is.
Yeah!
Oh, set.
Oh, a thousand.
Okay.
Where is he?
Is this a lovely view?
Don't you love it?
The tomato's always watching.
He's always watching you.
It's like the eye of Soron.
Oh my god, we should.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We should have the eye of Soran on top of the prison Wow Oh
wait Oh my god that's a brilliant idea I Request We should
have an eye of Soran Alright alright Is there a way?
Oh wait I just realized we can't have people build on my
land We can't We can't people build on my land because they
Alright Alright because I know you guys will break You guys
will try and Wait actually no it's made out of You guys
can't break any of this because it made out of obsidian uh
what is it called bedrock you can now with sub areas okay so
admin make this portion buildable on the top only this part
be buildable on the top with other dragoons this the on top
of the prison cell and then we'll let people in we'll start
letting people in but they can only so they can build this
area all
right admin but only the top part make sure they can't mess
with anything else and then wait wait admin can we lock
people into a specific area so they can't move out of there
is that possible are you really gonna build asking to build
the tower
Okay, it's a good Iosauron.
Thank you for the super chat, sir.
It's for good.
Okay, so what we're going to have to do, admin, is that
we're going to let people in, but they are locked into this
area so they can't move out of this particular area.
So they can't, like, follow me around and, like, slack off,
you know, while we...
Explore so we gotta make sure we gotta make sure they can
like slack off and don't we'll give you guys the supplies to
build it Don't worry I don't think we will we will give you
don't worry We will provide you the supplies all you have to
do is just you know Oh, am I lagging?
I didn't even realize I'm lagging.
How long was I lagging for?
Oh my god, I am what the fuck what is wrong with this?
part of the what was what is wrong with this part of the
area okay give me a set let me fix this is it all right let
me i've it's not that bad that's that bad oh my god 120 okay
that okay let's do 36 chunks there we go uh i didn't realize
that it was at 100.
Okay.
Okay, that makes a bit more sense.
That's a lot of clouds.
That is a lot of clouds.
Why am I lagging so much?
Options, video settings.
500 frames by maxing 140.
Wait, render.
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, whoa.
Whoa, that's a lot of chunks.
That's a lot of chunks.
Oh, whoops.
I just realized how many chunks that was.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
That should be a lot better.
That should be a bit better.
Okay, and then 12 chunks.
Okay.
Is that better?
No, I must have...
That's weird.
Let's see.
We'll fix this.
It kind of improved.
It's literally not any.
It kind of improved a bit.
But what is my...
No, that's weird.
Because, like, my CPU and memory are okay.
Oh, wait.
I'm okay now.
There you go.
Oh, I'm not okay.
I tap back in and I'm no longer okay.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, that was the thumb.
Try shift F3.
Once you're tabbed in.
Yeah, once I'm tabbed in, it's not okay anymore.
Why is that?
Maybe I should do...
240?
Maybe that would help.
Oh, no.
I made it worse.
We're just stuck at putting it back.
Turn it off full screen.
You think it's the full...
Oh, wait.
Oh, there we go.
It's back to normal.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
We're just letting our...
We'll explore while our admin figures...
Our admin's going to figure out how to lock people in to
build our stuff.
Wait, what blocks will we need, guys?
Sorry, I keep pressing R for refresh.
but like i keep i for some reason i keep thinking r i keep
pressing r for reload i'm like reload but i'm reloading my
texture all right while he's figuring okay what what
materials do you guys will you guys need to for my
volunteers uh to work on the eye of soron i of doki for the
eye of doki what would be the best polished blackstone okay
we'll give you there's a two for it okay l spawn two for it
all right let's see oh shit oh my god wait i'm playing two
team fortress two this is actually team fortress two oh
my god i'm trying to fly up wait no this oh my god it is
wait is this blue side wait where's red on the other side.
Oh my god, there's red.
Oh my god, it's literally TF2.
Oh my god.
There it is.
There's an infamous bridge.
Wait, is there a pipeline?
The sewers too.
Oh my god, they even built the sewers.
Oh my god, this is...
That's actually... Oh my god, that's actually fucking
awesome.
They actually... They fucking built T-Fortress 2.
We got T-Fortress 2 in Minecraft.
time for one hour one hour of two for it guys it's time oh
this i remember this area this is where i was uh this is
where i was like being a spy and oh that's so cool i like
that two four 24 7 quits that's so good i claim this area
property of doki law there you go i claim it's mine now
um it's mine now smile
it's like i placed the flag there it's like america this is
now this is now property of america i made this Oh, W.
Nice.
I like how this land is just called W.
Let's see.
Where else can we go?
How am I evil?
I own the server.
I can claim whatever.
You know what?
I'm claiming Alaska.
Property of Dokiman.
I'm going to claim Alaska now.
Oh, shit, we're using our...
Alright.
Spawn, do heal that.
Great.
Oh, that's cool.
Are you experimenting with our lovely raffle winner?
Nice.
Wait, can you make sure that they can't leave?
Wait, they can't leave, right?
Alright, put them in here and then test it out if they can
leave the area or not.
Set.
Time.
Wait.
What was it?
Time.
Set.
Day.
Yeah, we got tested out.
Make sure that they can't leave this specific area, and they
can't TP too.
Make sure you get rid of their TP rights.
Yeah, you're not supposed to be able to break anything.
Not up here.
We're going to give them outside time.
You know, like, you know how in prison they get time outside
but this isn't a prison this is a lovely resort that this
lovely guest won for being the lucky 500th customer they
click they click to claim their prize it's yard time
there must be oil under the tf2 map and it's deep they give
a super chat thank you thank you uh samuro they give a super
chat thank you thank you this is not a warcraft this lucky
individual click to claim for being the 500th lucky customer
to win a no expense paid vacation alright can you leave wait
he can wait he can can you like jump out can you jump
alright we might have to like encase them yeah we're gonna
oh um um um They're leaving
Wait, what do we Oh, there we go There we go, there we go We
fixed it Alright, now they can't leave Okay
Okay Nice We gotta make sure It's all the way Up We gotta
make sure it's a Okay, we'll make it tie Okay, make it all
the way I want the tower to be big So make it like Here Make
it the enclosed here.
All the way here.
Where I'm standing.
Like higher.
And then make it enclosed.
So they can't fly out.
We gotta make sure these people can't fly out.
We gotta make sure.
And then we also.
We also have to make sure.
They can't TP out too.
So we gotta get rid of their TP rights.
as well and and then so we can build the eye of soron or the
eye of doki
all right we gotta figure out the materials we wait where
did he go wait he's gone hey mod what where did he go why
did he leave
where did he go hey what happened to this to them where did
he go he's not there anymore
how did he get out
did you did he have TP rights get rid of his TP rights right
now also delete his Electra he TP'd out
make sure he cannot TP You know what?
Remove TP.
Restrict them.
Remove his rights.
There we go.
Now bring him back here.
All right.
No, he did.
I saw it.
All right.
Nice.
He's restricted.
All right, I'm going to experiment a little bit.
All right, place this block.
Place this block right now.
Place it down.
Okay, it works.
All right, good.
All right, that's good.
We did it.
All right.
Let them in and place them in here and restrict all of them.
I have a very...
I have a speech for them.
All right, let them in.
I got to have builders for my eye of Doki.
Make sure they're all in this particular spot, too.
All right, slowly TP them in here, and then restrict them.
All right.
Make sure you put them right here.
it's not a war crime they are volunteers here to build my
eye of joki that it's very but they're the eye is not evil
this is a different this is not an evil eye i'm just here to
casually surveillance people and and it's not it's not
slavery because they i would feed them see here Yo, you want
a little cookie?
Look at that.
Here's a cookie.
You can't say it's slavery, but you get fed cookies.
See?
Look at that.
Look at it.
You got a cookie.
All right.
TP them all here.
I would need... Get me...
I want at least 20 people here.
all right at least 20 people to start building while i
explore the rest of the world
i don't think that it's not slavery i'm feeding them cookies
only for people who are willing to work i don't take
freeloaders all right if they don't work we we we x i mean
we uh give them a another lovely vacation if they are not
willing to work we will give them a lovely vacation
all right are you all here what is this why are they salute
all right start restricting them when they're inside
start restricting these people one by one it's so nice no
get this out of here i want the eye of doki not this
bullshit my son all right here i'll feed you guys look at
that here's some cookies for all of you you're some lovely
cookies now you can't say I didn't feed you oh all right
nice we have two four lovely volunteers hey hey what you
doing this is not this is not a black block what are you
doing all right nice okay we have two four six lovely
workers all right we should get 10.
Get 10.
Admin.
I want 10 workers in here.
There we go.
Yeah, that's a good block.
Alright, that's a good block.
Just make sure that you can only build.
You can't break, so.
If I see anyone messing it up, I will send you into a nice
vacation.
For one month.
No expense paid for one month so don't mess this up all
right so uh what what blocks would you guys need all right
kick everyone else we got our we got lucky volunteers admin
kick everyone else out these are chosen workers
congratulations you all won an all no expense paid vacation
right here lovely in this lovely uh what's it one 10 by 10
block now kick everyone out that's not in that didn't win
the raffle
all right let's see oh wait they might don't worry guys set
don't worry i'll save the day set time time set don't worry
i'll save you all Now it's day time.
I'm your savior.
Alright guys.
Here's some.
Alright.
Let's see.
What do they need?
Black blocks.
Alright here.
Here.
Use this to build.
There you go.
Alright and then I'll give you guys stairs.
too and then chiseled all right these are all black and then
here's some wood too here you go here are and the concrete
powder and black concrete and black wool here you go these
should all work some way for the build wait where is it go
okay here you guys go and then um and then i'm giving you
all the black stuff to build the lovely eye of doki and then
all right so orange you're right here so here's the eye part
too here's the orange terracotta why did we build why did we
build a guys this is not guys why did you build why did you
build a fucking beacon Okay, instruction's unclear.
We are not trying to build a beacon here.
We are trying to build an eye of Toki.
Okay.
All right, here you go.
Here's orange.
Here's orange glass, too.
And then, there you go.
And then yellow.
I'll give you guys yellow as well.
I don't know what you need, so I'll add yellow as well.
Here you go.
That should be everything you need, right?
All right.
We'll come back later.
Mod.
Your job is to make sure.
Here.
Grab.
Are there whips in the...
Are there whips in Minecraft?
No.
Okay.
Your job is to make sure they keep working.
All right.
And if they don't, I'll let you decide the punishment.
We can replace you.
All right.
If you do.
not work we can replace you it's very easy use a fishing rod
yeah use the fishing rod if they if they do not work all
right by the end of the stream i better see an eye of doki
or i would not be very happy about it or i will not be very
happy about not having my eye My eye of Doki.
Alright, L.
Spawn.
I need to get L.
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
Don't worry, I believe in them.
I put like...
Okay, I know it doesn't look like anything yet, but I
believe in them.
I...
Sajian, thank you for...
The Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
I think they can do it.
Okay, you know what?
I'll feed them too.
I'll give them a bit, some food as well.
Mine!
Throw some, throw some chicken to them.
Feed the humble volunteers.
Yeah, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's not a war crime!
They're volunteers!
They want to be there!
See, and I gave them chicken.
Look at that.
I gave them chicken, too.
It's not kidnapping.
They wanted to be there.
Go to the left?
Haze, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Look, it's not, it's so, I'm making sure, they clocked in
for their nine to five.
Is this a racetrack?
What the fuck is this?
Wait, what the fuck is that?
Is that, what is this?
Is this Uma Musume?
What the fuck?
Yeah, is this Uma Musume?
What the fuck is this?
I'm going to be a journalist and expose all of the crap.
Well, good luck finding any.
There's no war crimes in Dokilan.
Oh my god.
Where are the horses?
Did I accidentally took all of them?
Wait, but where do the horses start?
Like, we can't break anything.
Well, that's on you.
You don't need to craft anything.
We'll give you the supplies This is terrible
Yeah, you guys better make a good Aesauron Or I'm taking you
all on a nice No expense paid vacation Where are they making
Alright, let's check Spawn Doki Lash all right let's just
let's check what the fuck
I'm not happy right now mod replace all of them
I demand you to replace them all
also TP them all into that cell TP the ones that mess TP
them into this tiny cell TP them in TP these past workers
into this cell and restrict all their perms all of them in
there they made me not happy please I'm not happy I'm please
I'm all of them if they can't work together they got fixed
their issues in the cell
this is a collective blood punishment you're a collectivist
group wait that's me too don't worry i have i have perms
there we go all right Anyway, wait, how did these guys get
in here?
Wait, put all of them!
I said all of them!
What the fuck is this?
Oh my god, wait, what happened?
Yeah, no, I'm not happy.
Put all the restricted people in there.
That's right.
What the fuck did they make?
Like, what is this?
What the fuck is this?
Like, it looks like a...
It's like an abstract guard field.
Yeah, what?
It looks like an abstract guard field right now.
I don't even know what I'm looking at.
are they all in the cage are they all in there all right
nice okay all right now okay now wipe this wipe this
monstrosity off of my fucking lovely prison cell
ugly this i hate it i hate this
That's right.
Wait, how did they get out?
Wait, how did he get out?
Wait, wait!
They're getting out!
Mine!
Like this!
Put them back in!
And restrict all privileges from this one person.
Put it back in!
Make sure they never leave.
That's right.
Oh my god.
It's because he has an eye of Ender.
That's it.
I will make sure he remove his eye of Ender.
I see you.
Don't think I don't see you.
There we go.
Or Ender Pearl.
Get rid of his Ender Pearl.
Are they all locked up?
Make sure they can never escape.
Wait, he got out.
She got out again.
That's it.
I'm taking her.
Don't make me wipe your inventory because I will.
Don't make me remove...
Ask for forgiveness or I will remove your inventory right
now.
What?
Okay.
Yeah.
Put her back in there.
That's right.
Oh, hey there.
Look, he's happy.
There we go.
All right.
Let's grab some new workers.
We're going to grab... Oh, hey.
Nice.
You know what?
I believe in you two.
You two won't mess it up, right?
You won't mess it up, right?
All right, grab some new workers.
We need new workers in this prison cell.
I mean, in this, in the Iosauron.
Oh, don't worry.
I'll save you guys.
Time, set, day.
There we go.
All right.
Now that the new workers know what happened to the old
workers, they'll work just as hard.
Wait, how did you guys?
How did this guy get here?
Wait a minute.
That's fucking right.
You think I'm trying to break some prisoners out?
You're trying to now you're that's right.
My!
There's a guy that's trying to break out!
Oh, what are you doing here?
slash but we're mad all right don't mess with me all right
do we have new all right nice we did it all right all right
grab now uh mod grab a fishing pool and make sure they are
all working diligently oh I see you who's that over there
oh oh
your items will be gone forever
you see that you see your fellow yeah you see all his all
look at all his items there look at that what they that's
right you try to hide you try that's right look at all your
beautiful items to disappear that's right that's what you
get for trying to hide from me oh wait i should grab a goat
horn too oh my god they have all right there you go that's
right build build my workers
Bands for me!
How do I TP myself in there?
I forgot, admin.
How do I do that?
Wait, what happened to the server?
Oh, okay.
Oh, look, the items are gone.
Oh, okay, there we go.
TP.
Look at you.
Do you regret it?
Do you regret what you did?
You lost all your items.
That's right.
Run.
You had to do nothing but run with your empty pockets.
That's right.
And you all get to go.
I can get a new one.
What?
Toki, please.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Look at that.
I'm working so hard.
You know what?
Let me TP myself in here.
TP, Toki, Burrito, to Who is it?
Well, TP to There we go.
wait what are you doing in here wait why is there a leak
wait why is there a leak in here
what happened yeah you guys having fun yeah you idiot
that's right if you guys didn't fuck up as a group how come
this group was able to build it group was fine.
This group was fine.
Oh yeah, this guy.
Here we go.
That's right.
You're in a water prison now.
You can't leave.
This was my month.
I didn't even think of this.
That's right.
You can't leave.
You're in a water prison.
What can you Dude, no!
You're traveling water!
That's right!
That's right.
Don't fuck with me.
Do you see what happened to your friend?
Did you see what happened to your friend there?
You'll be next if you try and get out.
Here you go.
It's not a war crime.
He was just swimming.
You know what?
It's not a war crime, guys.
All right.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
It's working.
It's working, guys.
Oh, my God.
The I am toky.
Let's go.
It's raining.
making guys.
We're making it the eye of Doki.
They're doing so well.
Why couldn't you guys do that?
Laughing, you can't say that.
You're part of the group.
You were part of the group.
Yay!
Why can't you be more like that?
We moved on from war crimes to crimes against humanity.
I'm Canadian.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yay!
We couldn't, this could have been a bit taller to be fair,
but you know what, you know, You know, I ain't good effort.
Good effort.
You guys already are improvement from those people.
From that group.
What is corn pressure doing here?
He TP'd out.
He saw me looking and TP'd out.
Mod.
Put corn pressure into the water chambers.
Right now.
Don't think I didn't see him.
I saw him.
I saw him in there.
I didn't run, couldn't run.
I saw him.
Put him in the water chamber.
There you go.
Wait.
Oh my god.
He TP'd out.
Restrict him.
Restrict him now.
There is no escape.
You can escape, bro.
You think TPing out is going to save you?
We lost one today.
We...
Zero days since the last accident.
All right, there you go.
put him in that's right wait how is he still able to TP what
did you do restrict his privileges
there we go
he figured out the loophole what's the loophole what is it
don't wait don't say it out loud don't say it out loud so
they don't know the loophole
they're all yelling at each other look at that see this is
why you guys couldn't work as a team you all had to work
together look at you fighting each other this is your fault
no this is your fault all right do you guys do you guys need
any extra materials there we go you got the loophole patch
that's good don't worry i'll Don't worry, we're fine.
Don't worry, it's daytime.
Don't worry, I saved this all.
Bump, bottom.
One day, the troop will set us free.
Do you guys need extra materials?
Are you guys good?
There's only...
Now there's only five.
Yeah, we had a lot of people die, unfortunately.
we had we might have had a lot of people die during the
building just like just like the real iosura we might have
had some people that died from building this all right what
materials do you guys need it is what it is stacks of never
right okay no you're not getting netherite blocks.
You're not you're definitely not getting netherite blocks.
You're so sad.
Why do you look so sad?
Is it because you're locked in here?
Why are y'all so sad?
Has he figured out the loophole yet?
How do you fix the loophole mod?
Is Is corn pressure?
Oh, wait, he left.
Oh, he signed out.
You coward.
You goddamn coward.
Even when being cased in the water prison.
Oh, my God.
It's beautiful.
The eye.
The eye of Doki.
Oh, wait.
He got bad.
Wait.
What did he got?
He got bad.
Look at that.
It's beautiful.
I would have liked it to be a little taller, but we'll
figure, we'll do that later.
Don't worry.
That's for offstream, uh, offstream volunteers.
I believe.
Oh my god.
They're like actually constructing stuff.
Look at them.
Look at them go.
I like how these guys are working.
working so hard together and like this group is still
fighting each other and they still fight wait who's that
wait a minute i saw you i saw you
that's right don't mess with me
Toki, what the fuck?
He tried to break in.
I saw him try to do a prison break.
No prison breaks allowed.
No, he tried to do a prison break here.
All right.
Oh, my God, it's coming out beautifully, guys.
Look at that.
Let this be a lesson.
go explore a little bit more we'll explore a little bit more
he's gonna work on it when they are oh god all right we'll
explore a little bit more bye why don't they show how to
explore while they're doing their remember use the fishing
pull mod use the fishing pull lavi thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you palm pet thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you um Echoing from the water chambers
below Shire pagans the user for chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I mean someone can pay your bell lafie Oh, yeah,
what's this?
What the fuck?
What?
Wait, where?
Where is the room?
Okay.
Okay, first off.
Why are there fucking flowers?
There's a tired world.
It's just flowers.
Oh my god.
Nice.
I can't, I can't, I can't, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't let Lafey out.
They ruined it.
Okay.
Oh, oh my God.
I like how, I like how there's sheep surrounding his animals
around here.
That is crazy.
That is actually crazy.
Oh my God.
That is beautiful.
And it's moving too.
Oh my god.
The amount of time to build that.
The fact that someone made a twerk is crazy.
Why was this?
Fan fix.
Oh hey, it has my hair.
What are the fan fix here?
Alright.
Oh, it's Germany!
They still have my...
Oh, they're here.
There's my bedrock right here.
Laughing, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I built the beacon.
I did more than you.
The beacon wasn't part of the eye of Doki.
What do you mean?
You both fucked up.
Your entire group fucked up.
Oh yeah, there's the headquarters.
Alright, what else?
What else is there to explore?
oh that's cute that's really cute the little like skyline oh
there's the weeping peepie are they still fighting in there
then spawn dookilon make it stop raining i don't like it but
how did you get out There you are.
Yeah, you traveled a long time to get here, didn't you?
Yeah, you did.
I'm not that evil.
Oh, look at that!
Is it almost done?
What else?
You guys have...
Okay, it's a little lopsided, but you know, it's already a
huge improvement from before.
It's okay.
You guys did a lot better than the other group.
I already I'll give you guys that You guys already did a lot
better From the other group It is a little lopsided but
that's okay
What a bum Wait what are they trying to do now?
Oh they met What are they trying to do?
Is it done?
Are you guys done?
Is the group Done?
I need to know what else are they no what is what is left
not you i'm not talking about the old group i'm talking
about the new group i you guys can't talk for them oh yeah
we lost a lot of the workers uh
i'm talking to the new group if they're done or not
I didn't ask for their opinion.
I asked for the new group's opinion.
I think we should make it skinnier.
We just didn't get it.
What do you mean?
They had the new group had the same amount of instructions
as the old group.
Yet somehow they were actually able to build the eye of
Doki.
I believe they had the same amount of instructions.
This is just a prototype.
This is a pretty good prototype.
You know what?
This is pretty good.
I...
This is really good.
For five people, we used to have more, but they sort of died
during the building of this.
But...
But yeah, literally skillet.
issue for their skill issue from this group to the old group
i would say that these people these people in the new group
were able to construct an adequate eye of doki for me look
at that look at this 360 view you know what i feel so
generous right now give me a sec uh tp doki to what what's
his Bucky.
Okay, there you go.
All right, I feel so generous.
Look.
Look at that.
My people, I shall reward you.
I'll reward you 13 diamonds.
Look at that.
Woo!
It's raining diamonds.
Congratulations.
Some new diamonds.
You know, I feel so generous.
Look at that.
Oh my god, look at them.
They're like fish.
They're like fish right there.
Do you see that?
They're like just, you know what?
I feel so generous.
I feel so generous that I shall reward with one, one
Netherite block of Netherite.
Come over here.
Yeah, yeah, my little fishies.
My little fishies who wants this block of Netherite.
It's right.
Whoa!
I can't...
I'm like feeding fish right now.
You let him jump up and down.
That's her!
Only one.
One
more food!
Oh, that's so cute.
I want more food.
I'm so hungry.
Okay, okay, keep that so much.
Okay, okay, okay.
I feel... I feel so generous.
Alright.
You know what?
I...
I'll give.
Here you go.
I'll give me one netherite ingot right here.
Alright, come on.
Jump for me, fishies.
Jump.
Fishies.
Look at that.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
Good job, guys.
Good job.
An ingot is still...
Alright, there you go.
Now go back to work.
This is Fuck.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, here you go.
This is, you know, every time she plays, this, it gets
worse.
Alright.
Go back to work now.
I'm here to observe.
No, no, they have extra stuff they want to put.
See, look, they're adding extra stuff.
Yeah, at least clean up our poop.
It's overflowing.
No!
I said, I said we clean it up once every month.
Oh yeah, give them fish too.
Here we go.
Here we go, guys.
Here's a bucket of tropical fish.
If anyone wants it.
Alright, that's nice.
These guys are working so hard.
Look at them go.
BADAM BADAM Look at them go I'm so generous I'm not an evil
person I'm a generous god I literally gave them netherite
I gave them netherite Look at them go TP Oh my L Spawn Doki
Lan.
Wait, how did he...
Wait, how did he get out?
Wait a minute.
Alright, that's not good.
Wait, Mod.
Someone got out.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Mod, we have an escapee!
Get over here!
That's right.
I don't think I don't see you.
Yeah, that's right.
You think you can run?
I'm tracking you down right now.
That's it.
I don't know where to put you in.
Slash TP.
Doki Berto.
All right.
Give me a sec.
I gotta get someone in here.
Slash TP.
Work.
Congratulations.
You are the 500th customer.
Click here to claim
That's right Now work
It's a promotion I keep thinking she's got you know what?
TP Bob Work Wait, how do I restrict them?
Restrict.
Bob.
Wait.
Mod.
Restrict this man.
Bob Ross, the 20th.
Restrict him right now.
Bob Ross.
Restrict him.
That's right.
Okay.
T.P.
Bob.
There you go.
Now work.
Work.
Work for me.
Glory to Doki Bird.
Yay.
All right.
We're doing it, guys.
Yeah.
It's like...
It's like we're building the pyramids.
Oh, hey, the shopping district.
Does not negotiate.
Blackjack is here.
harm him and there will be blackjack twos wait who's
blackjack two is this that's jack black which one's
blackjack two does that says keep gambling blackjack two
isn't a dragon anymore
i don't need a i already have blackjack one i don't need a
second horse oh did i kill The first blackjack?
I don't remember.
All the horses.
All the tributes have been blurred together.
All the tributes blurred together for me.
Let's see.
Okay, this one is a...
Oh, I did.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
I think that...
Are you sure it was me?
It might have been an accident.
You know?
You know what?
Mine.
Get over here.
I have a task for you.
take this horse mine take this horse and hide him
underground hide him deep underground go underground build
like a small enclosure underground and then hide him where
is he going with ours slash kill
all right go underground all the way underground find
somewhere underground and then put this horse in there he's
still alive but he's somewhere underground how did you keep
coming up with these ideas what that's so messed up he's
still alive blackjack 2 is still alive but where is
blackjack 2 you gotta dig underground to find him you'll
have to dig underground to find him
deep deep underground so deep to be near bedrock but but um
alex thank you the super chat thank you thank you it can't
be in the shopping district find an area deep underground
for you to make a little spot for him and then put him there
it's like the one piece we're trying to you're trying to
find the one piece but for blackjack too
el mexican all because el mexican all because el mexican did
not sign in this is his fault
if he was online that day we would have had a normal day we
that's all i'm saying he wasn't there for his for his prison
I mean for his free expense no like no expense paid vacation
in the cell what a moment we need him the most he vanished
but don't know
not if it's you don't know where exactly we're gonna put him
you don't know where you i keep digging too to find him yeah
but you're wasting your time to get him but there i'm on did
you find a place yeah i got get off how do i get off the
horse if you're oh here you go all right why is there a
golem attached to this get out of here there we go all right
is he you got him all right nice we've teleported him all
right he's gone
no one will know where he lives oh there's the pokemon
center there yeah
oh it logged the coordinates all right all right after the
stream mod after the stream After this stream, close the
server, close the server, and re-hide the horse.
So you won't know the coordinates.
Alright.
Well, you guys, we thought of everything.
Kilan.
Did you guys finish?
Did you guys finished it?
Whoa!
Oh my god, more workers died.
We lost so much men at the work site.
Oh my god.
Wait, who's this?
Mine!
Restrict him!
New worker!
We have a new worker!
Restrict this man!
Freeze!
New worker, restrict him.
His name was Freeze.
Underscore F-R-E-E-Z-E.
And then send him back in here.
That's right, restrict him.
He's right here.
F-R-E-Z-Z-E.
There we go.
Work.
Prison break.
Wait a minute.
Maude!
We had a prison break!
Get back here!
Maude!
We have a prison break!
Oh wait, El Mexicans back here.
Okay, TP put him back in here.
Put him back in the cell.
Oh, you know, just put El in there.
You know what?
I'm feeling just put El in there.
Put him back here.
Alright, never mind.
You don't have to put anyone else in the cell.
there.
We don't need anyone else in there.
Alright.
Yay!
Look at my lovely workers.
Look at them go.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Look at it.
It's beautiful.
Is it done now?
Is it done?
Who is your representative new group?
Are you done?
You guys think so?
Wait, is he like an actual worker that said that?
Or like...
Oh yeah, okay.
Alright.
Get rid of the bamboo stuff.
I need the ascetic.
Get rid of all the bamboo, like, benches stuff.
Alright, nice, nice, nice.
Alright, get down.
Stand, like, stand over here all the workers all the workers
stand over here stand over here all the workers stand over
here guys i need all the workers to be over here over here i
have a special treat for you guys just stay there stay there
stay there just stay there don't move don't move don't move
don't move guys how do i change pov again i don't remember
video v again which one f5 okay guys look I built this take
a photo guys I built this look at that guys you guys like my
build yeah I call it the eye of doge hey what are you guys
doing it stand behind the build all right you guys like my
build I this guys I am Doki is yeah look at that the I am
Doki I did that okay guys you guys did a great job guys wow
good job now you guys we did it okay now you guys can get
out of there you guys can get out of there now you guys can
get out of behind them oh i got you guys a treat wait wait
don't worry don't worry i am a good person i'll give you
guys a little prize for all your hard work don't worry here
you guys go i was ready for your treat
here you guys go come on come on you guys ready for your
little treat
Look at that.
Here you guys go.
My little fishies.
Yum, yum.
Congratulations.
Congratulations, everyone.
What a productive day today.
Yeah, you can make bread with that.
Wait, how did they get out?
Wait, how did these people get out?
Wait, no, that's not high enough
Wait, oh, you're lucky.
What?
What did I get that?
On
my pocket How did that get in my hand?
Whoa, hold on
You know what?
I had a good productive day today in Minecraft.
What a nice day.
Alright.
Now leave my property.
Leave my land.
No squatters.
Get out.
Wait.
Why can't I attack them?
Wait a minute.
Mine!
Why can't I attack these people?
Maude, fix this!
Fix this!
I can't hit my...
I can't hit them with my stick!
They are in control.
Can't get out of prison?
No.
Wait, how do all you guys...
Wait a minute.
This isn't allowed here.
You know what?
Kick them all out!
I wouldn't mind my handiwork.
Munch!
Kick them all out!
If I can't hit them with my...
With my bonk stick?
Then we kick them all out.
Mine!
Mom!
Laramie, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Except for Mexicon.
Except for El Mexicon.
Wait, where did they all go?
Where did they all go?
Keep El Mexicon in that jail.
In his prison set.
I mean in his lovely hotel room.
Except for him.
He gets to stay in there.
And then put Blackheart into the water chamber too.
Put him in the water chamber.
There we go.
You see the Blackheart?
Put him in the water chamber.
Yeah.
What?
It's just like, wait, what?
There you go.
Nice.
All right.
Peace and quiet.
There you go.
My lovely workers for your, you know what?
I'm feeling very generous right now.
So, for being, for building such an amazing tower, I shall
reward you another gift from your humble God and Duchess and
ruler of Doki Lod.
I shall reward you.
Look at that.
Here you go.
Come on, my children.
Eat, my children.
Whoa!
Eat.
The yummy, yummy food.
There you go.
Look at them go.
They're running around.
Yum, yum.
This is the good shit.
That's right.
I gave you the good shit, the good food right there.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
See?
Look at them.
They built my shrine.
All right.
I feel like I think Hello there Hello It's like me tapping
the glass being like Hey there
I fed my yeah I fed my fishes Yeah the fish glass right now
but that was fun today was a fun day I had my map and my
jump scare um but today was a fun productive day on the
dokey smp for those who want to join the who's doing that
give me a sec what the fuck who's doing that
Oh, he's so lucky
You're so lucky
JK I had a very productive day today on the Doki SMP If any
of you guys want to join the Doki SMP to join the membership
and follow the instructions pinned in chat and you too can
have a fun day with me on the smp server see i mean did you
all have fun did you all have fun see look at look at all of
them see yes yes yes mod kill everyone that said no look at
them they all said yes
much note down all everyone that said no and then please uh
take them to have let them have a very nice vacation um down
the farm uh that's my no i'm back to cori thank you thank
you thank you
take them out to have a very nice vacation down at the farm
but i always have fun with you guys messing around on the uh
on the server uh i'm gonna head off now i'm gonna chill a
little bit today like i said this week is more like a chill
day a chill hangout uh a chill week this week is a chill
week for me um but i like messing around with you guys um
and oh yeah we should build a farm next week next week we'll
build a farm for anyone that you know you know wants to have
a little fun you know who decides to have an extra you know
people who i want to um take i want to take some people
there to the farm you know to have a little fun have their
vacation you know Yes?
A nice little vacation down at the farm.
Turkey had a little farm.
E-I-E-I-O.
The fun farm.
Anyway, good luck to my mod for fixing all the stuff I did
today.
Good luck.
Good luck to that mod.
You've got to fix all the things I did today.
Anyway.
it was definitely a fun time messing about with all the guys
yeah maybe we should what should we build next next month I
like the eye part obviously this will be improved more
upstream I don't know what to build next I want to build a
pyramid guys we should build a pyramid all right next month
we're building a pyramid And then like inside will be like
where I hide all my treasures
We're gonna build a pyramid together guys
Yeah yeah I want to build a pyramid I'm gonna find let's go
to the desert and build a giant ass pyramid My tomb yeah I'm
gonna be a pharaoh now I clean first I was a duchess then an
emperor then a queen, then a king, and I feel like the next
step is to be a pharaoh.
Oh, what's this?
Where am I?
Where did...
Where did my mod take me?
I don't even know.
Oh, it's a satellite dish right here.
What the fuck?
There's a satellite dish.
Yeah, but that's not the pyramid I want.
I want it to be a big pyramid.
Fit for a pharaoh.
No, no, no.
Not my pyramid.
I want a big pyramid.
I need a big one.
Anyway, guys.
I'm going to call it here.
As always, everyone, let's go back to my house where we just
hear the bell over and over again.
Time set there.
All right, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
check, get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up from me, head to bed, cause you deserve
it.
next time everyone bye guys um oh bye